[Musique]
il est clair que nous ne souhaitons pas
et je pense que nous sommes nombreux ici
à ne pas souhaiter qu'une telle
consultation populaire ait lieu le jour
des élections européennes on peut pas
mélanger les
choses il est indispensable qu'on puisse
avoir un vrai débat portant sur la
construction européenne c'est la raison
pour laquelle monsieur Premier ministre
nous souhaitons que la France retrouve
le rôle moteur qui doit être le sien en
Europe et que nous puissions avoir ce
débat évitons d'avoir si c'est le cas un
référendum le jour des élections
européennes aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président rien n'est décidé je sais que
nous vivons dans un monde où dès lors
que on commence à réfléchir à une
hypothèse elle se transforme
immanquablement en un fait puis en une
vérité puis on peut évoquer et je dirais
même réfléchir et consulter sur cette
idée je crois que c'est important et je
vous rejoins parfaitement monsieur le
Président le scrutin qui interviendra le
26 mai pour les européennes sera un
scrutin d'une importance
considérable absolument considérable
pour la construction européenne et pour
notre pays référendum ou pas monsieur le
sénateur depuis très longtemps les
élections européennes sont le moment où
on parle finalement assez peu des
élections européennes et beaucoup de
tique nationale nous le savons tous nous
l'avons tous vécu et nous n'avons pas
envie que cela recommence je ne crois
pas en tout état de cause que un seul
référendum quand bien même il porterait
sur plusieurs projets de loi suffirait à
traiter à intégrer l'ensemble de ce qui
est dit et si j'ose dire mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de ce qui est
dit et de ce qui n'est pas
dit
les pauvres élections européennes
n'avaient rien demandé et un référendum
pour répondre à des manifestants d'hier
et d'aujourd'hui qui disent trop
d'impôts trop de taxes pas assez de
pouvoir d'achat une dépense publique à
revoir trop de contraintte réglementair
et on envisage un référendum qui dit on
va parler du Parlement est-ce que c'est
une vraie piste du gouvernement vers
quoi va-t-on pour sortir du grand débat
ce grand débat achevé il faudra en tirer
les conséquences cela a été clairement
dit de manière précise et concrète il
appartiendra alors au chefs de l'État et
au chefs du gouvernement de faire les
choix qui s'imposeront monsieur le
ministre carucci je connais trop votre
engagement goliste et votre attachement
aux institutions de la 5e République
pour croire que le recours à un
référendum serait pour vous criticable
en soi mais en tout cas il faut concl où
nous parlons cette question n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour je n'ai aucune
appréhension par rapport à un référendum
je pense que le Président de la
République on aurit davantage les
Français ont le droit de savoir ce qui
est l'issue de ce grand débat si vous
voulez faire une réforme
constitutionnelle complète pas juste des
bricoles de l'article 11 mais
l'utilisation du 89 une vraie réforme
vraie République transformée n'hésitez
pas il y a un parlement pour ça et je
vais vous dire Monsieur le Premier
Ministre 348 sénateurs 577 députés 925
parlementaires 925 citoyens rien mais
348 sénateurs 577 députés 925
parlementaires élu de manière directe ou
indirecte c'est la
[Applaudissements]
France